so the heading is chairs now um how many
of you have done Commerce or doing
anything like that yeah so you can
someone give me a one sentence
definition like the simplest you can
boil it down for the rest of us who
radicular will be challenged so what uh
what is okay it's hot of a company that
you can buy is perfect let's go back
watashi is the whole idea of sharing out
a company sharing ownership is it's like
Luke I want to be a pot learner and I'm
willing to pay for the privilege right
so it's part of the company that you can
buy that's really nice simply okay now
oh is it for any company the answer is
the third if you are the company of this
directly goes to our next question right
if you're the company why on earth would
you sell pieces of your company you tell
people okay number one obviously the
only reason why anyone actually sells
things is so that they can make money
but I kind of like if I go to company up
for blood send trees into making this
thing I don't just give that to anyone
so what am I actually gonna get out of
it like what's the point of having them
okay excellent this whole idea of loans
right we've talked about before under
simple and compound interest if you say
I'm going to be able to access more
funds as a company then I can do stuff
right like if I have temporary access to
an extra thousand ten thousand 1 million
dollars think of what kind of adventures
I can do okay
now therefore putting these two together
okay if you are a person who is buying
shares that makes you a shareholder
right because you hold these bits of the
company okay so shareholders
shareholders will have some number of
shares the company gets the shareholders
money cool I can do stuff with this in
return what they say is okay you've got
some shares as my company succeeds and
grows and gets bigger okay I'm going to
give you some money back right your
shares they'll increase in value okay so
why from the company's point of view
they get more they get their hands on
more money they can do stuff with it
that's right so there's more support for
like you know I actually I can do
something risky have not known oh it's
all my personal money that's gonna go
down at any place on your own but
secondly from the point of view I'd like
to say us as shareholders you're giving
up your money in order to have access to
access to the growth of a company so
you've got these shares right suppose
you buy one share in facebook right
which is really expensive as the company
grows your shares grow with the company
right and in fact what I'd like you do
is just draw up a sign here
throw me a pizza now shares really I
like buy one slice of the pizza okay so
if I've got this slice over here
forget that really accurate peppery um
you can see if the whole pizza gets
bigger right
if you earn what ate the pizza then your
slices also getting P not okay and maybe
you buy it for some amount of time and
then decide okay I kind of work this
money back now I'm going to sell the
share back either back to the company
like goodwill retain ownership or I
might sell it to a key or feels like
cool I won't in on that pizza thing
Billy it's growing right so I bought it
at some amount of money if grew and then
I'm gonna sell it and make a profit does
that make sense so you can see it's well
sometimes if if you know heaven forbid
my pizza gets smaller there's a terrible
thought I never want to come to play if
my features get smaller if the company
is struggling its ventures didn't
succeed then yeah my shares gonna get
smaller and smaller it's in my interest
to get rid of it before it becomes
nothing okay so you can see by the way
and it's really important you get both
of these when it comes to economic thing
really then at last we'll take off
things like these schemes like this
don't loss or take off unless they
include clear benefits for both parties
and here if you're the company or if
you're the shareholder these are both
really good things so now I gotta focus
on the house okay and that's that's
where the maths comes into play okay we
need to know a few more words and bits
and pieces okay
so firstly you already know what shares
are churches have what we call I need um
market daily or face value
so market value simply is how much you
have to pay to get one share or how much
your share is worth okay now to F
mentioning just like I have with my
pizza you right as the company is like
the CEO or a board of directors or
whatever I can cut my pizza my company
into as few or as many slices shares as
I like right I could make it eight
slices or I could make it 100 or I could
make it ten thousand right so the
moisture is they are a smaller each
value will be does that make sense so
you need to have a look when you go on
an intimate I would ask you to get a
line go pull up the Australian Stock
Exchange and the American one as well so
you can see the values of things like
wow this shares like hundreds of dollars
for a single chair well you know what
maybe the company just doesn't have that
many of them it just kind of depends
every company all different others okay
so that was number one market value no
you keep this sorry all market price
number two we want to talk about
dividends okay dividends again I'm going
to call on the economics of commerce
people can someone give me a one
sentence simple language just like this
definition of a dividend yeah very good
so remember when I talked about my slice
of pizza getting bigger so suppose my
whole pizza became this big right so my
individual slice has also increased in
size okay that increases this part here
that's the dividend that would represent
like my profit if I sold it to someone
else
okay so a dividend is extra value return
to shareholders
shareholders they could put it a for
everything like I suppose um it's really
important as a company right companies
tend to release quarterly reports about
how they going and about what the
dividends are for their shareholders
because they're obliged to do that ah
let's eat
oh you know what here two more two more
sorry I'm working on this video
okay now I'm matching these two things
together matching these two things
together is what we call percentage
yield because my market values it might
be because more right like I said those
shares could be really about what spawn
value if I said to you hey my dividend
for each share that I earn em you know
this pizza company I might say the
dividends a dollar per share but that
doesn't mean anything to you until you
know how much the shares of work okay
$1 per share could be nothing if each
shares worth like $200 and I increased
by $1 it's like well good for you you're
probably going to lose that door in the
next hour it's gonna fluctuate up and
down okay
on the other hand if every share I
bought at 50 cents then a dividend of $1
that's pretty good
that's like it's tripled in size and
went from 50 cents to a dollar 50 does
that make sense so being that I want to
be able to compare these two that's why
we go to percentages okay so if percent
is you I'm actually give you a formula
here the percentage yield is the amount
of the dividend so like I said a dollar
and you want to divide that by the
market value of the market price
of course that is just going to give you
a decimal if I want to convert that to a
percentage I'm going to multiply that by
and that will actually simply nobody
just like we were used to in interest
rates River I said suppose I got that
extra dollar right that was the amount
of the diamond so I might say I might
say the amount of my dividend was a
dollar and I bought a share at 50 cents
right let's see what's happening here so
what I've multiplied by a hundred
percent and if you check this into your
calculator that's a hundred cents 50
cents 150 years a hundred divided by 50
years here hundred ride by 50 that's
right yeah well done guys in the
afternoon you're feeling very confident